She knows a myth to fight off the powerful enemy more when compared to the Persians
It's pretty small right? When you're that small, who cares? Yeah, you tell us about it
No, I'll tell you something that you may not know one man by himself can change the course of history
You just wait you're going to see how that's too much. No, no, no, but he's a noble animal the horse for King an expert horseman will show us go on
You try and see.
No, no, no, no, I just, I, I, I, I, I could never ask.
Xander, why would you succeed?
Because the others weren't watching, but you must forgive them.
Oh, boasting a little, aren't we?
Please, let me try.
Notice something about this horse.
He's afraid of his shadow.
Xander named Cephalus, and it was to carry him far and wide to places where no man had gone before.
Holy tell us, maestro.
Where's Macedonia exactly?
Macedonia was a very small country, located, located, eh, located, eh, just north of Greece,
But in a few years, just as his father had predicted, Alexander had forged a great empire.
Greatest empire that civilization has ever known.
And he did that all alone?
No, no, of course not. Many people had a hand in it.
One man had a great influence on Alexander.
But he didn't pay close attention, and that was too bad.
He was a great philosopher who looked rather like, um, hmm.
Aristotle, I was looking for you. I need you.
Philip of Macedonia. Will I greet you, sire? What can I do for you, Your Majesty?
My son, Alexander, you must prepare him to be king.
And why have you come to me?
Because you and Plato are our greatest philosophers.
It's true. A king must be brave in battle, but must also be wise. I'll teach him.
Awareness comes from our senses, so we can tell what's real from what only appears to be real.
But all that appears real has to be explained by reason,
because that is how we discover the hidden truth of our observations.
Look around you. Your senses tell you the earth is flat.
Yes, there are mountains and valleys, but it's flat.
Now, have you seen an eclipse of the moon?
Yes, once I did, but there was kind of a shadow over it.
That was caused by...
Well, um...
It was the Earth's shadow. Draw it. Go on.
If the Earth is flat, why does the shadow form a curved line?
Is it 'cause the Earth is round like a ball?
Exactly.
And really large?
Thousands, millions of times larger than all Macedonia.
I guess that means Macedonia is really small.
Well, in a way...
Tell us, what is the trouble?
from the mountain. He killed one of our sheep, and we're all frightened.
I can fight a lion with my bare hands.
That's not bravery, it's foolishness.
I'm not brave, Aristotle.
Know that the coward flees danger and hides, cowering before power.
The foolhardy man rushes to danger without thinking.
Whereas, the truly courageous man confronts danger, but using his reason, facing a lion
with bare hands is foolhardy. Reason lets man create weapons, which increase his power
in a fight.
But I'm not an ordinary man. The blood of the gods runs in my veins.
My ancestor Achilles was a god.
Oh, you're immortal, then.
Gods are immortal. Don't you know that?
Stop and think, Alexander. I know Macedonian.
I know that all Macedonians are mortals.
Yes, so?
Aren't you a Macedonian?
So I'm a Macedonian.
You are a Macedonian. All Macedonians are mortal.
Ergo, you are mortal. That is logic.
That we shall see.
Where is this lion of yours? I'll tame him.
Come, I'll show you.
Pick up your weapons and follow them.
Is he?
Father Philip of Macedonia is a great king and he is also a very great man.
But he is still a man, and humans, as with animals, produce their own kind.
I believe, Alexander, you are only a man.
Emotions.
Respect you as I do my dad.
He's the one who gave me life, and you teach me how to live it wisely.
Love for his father and wisdom.
Soon he's going to have to choose between them.
Because when his father takes for his second wife, the beautiful Cleopatra,
she will soon have the future king of Macedonia.
You insinuating that I am illegitimate. Oh Macedonians your king who would lead you to Asia
Bulls when walking from one table to the next naturally after this Alexander had to flee far from the royal palace
Yes, mother. I'm fine. Alexander. I am not worried
You are invincible immortal my son told you my son. Your father was not Philip of Macedonia that paltry king
With a thunder Zeus king of all gods created you. It's about time. I've been waiting for you
I said, don't you know, Alexander?
This world is as nothing.
See not riches as the purpose and goals of the good life.
You, what are you doing?
Diogenes, a philosopher.
And Diogenes, is there anything at all that I can do for you?
Move aside, you're blocking the sun.
By all the gods, if I weren't Alexander, I would like to be Diogenes.
This is ready to follow you, Alexander.
If you will free us from the Persians.
Sure, Greece, but not us Spartans, not us.
At the time, Persia had the greatest empire ever known.
It extended right to India, China, Russia, all the way to Egypt.
And it included countries that today are called Afghanistan and Pakistan, Iran, Iraq, Syria, Israel, Lebanon, even Turkey.
The Persians could raise an army of a million men.
And it was said that their army had so many soldiers that if they drank the river, it would dry up.
Oh, by the golden sword.
Look here, sir.
It's dried up?
Yes, I know.
I know the gods are with me.
Forward!
Xander, and you will know many successes, but remember, don't be ruled by your fiery nature.
you must rule it.
His army has reached Asia.
His soldiers number 30,000.
He's mad.
Our 100,000 will soon dispatch this puny Macedonian into the sea.
The Greeks will surely come from here.
With their dawn attack, they will have the sun in their eyes.
We will position our troops on this ridge.
However, the Persians are on the opposite side.
Dawn.
It's just what the Persians think we'll do.
But look there.
The sun is behind us and in their eyes.
We attack them and right now.
You, Parmenio, will command on the left.
Ptolemy, you will take the right.
I'll take the center.
Phyllis the painter and Lysippus the great sculptor.
They'll immortalize you.
Finish all that later.
I can't waste all this time.
I have a whole world to conquer.
Come on, Philatis.
Follow me.
Man, but it needs more red and the arm is too skinny.
Be too skinny, but at least it didn't fall off.
Philatis is not made of marshmallow.
Greek cities along the coast of Asia Minor were liberated
and Alexander advanced toward the interior.
Guardian, ancient citadel of King Midas.
King Midas was touched, turned everything to gold.
Look is the chariot here. This chariot belonged to our old King Gordius
Yes, the the chariot is here because an oracle said the one who can undo the Gordian knot will be the master of Asia
Tento word starts word ends too hard
Nobody can untie us. It's not possible. He's sore. And he's the master of Asia. Xander's army is powerful grows every day
He's already conquered Phrygia.
Sire, you should take command!
Very well, I shall lead the troops and I'll teach that Macedonian a good lesson.
Sidereus has raised a large army. They're marching on us now.
He said he has a million soldiers.
Ah, then why are we waiting?
Sire, you realize we're strongly outnumbered?
Wait, it's not finished.
Me, boss, we were out to one.
We will march all night and wait at Isis Pass.
There we will destroy them.
Damascus and bringing back from there more than 300 cooks and 50 garland weavers 300 dancing girls
the way to persia is now open but alexander turns and heads for egypt the tyrians managed to
create a few problems for him gaza was another hard nut to crack greek fire it was a novelty
that was all the rage at last here they are beside the nile river and it is here that he
founds his city, his port, Alexandria. He hopes it will become a beacon of Greek culture, shining
out to the rest of the world. He goes on hundreds of miles across the desert to the temple of
Sionat-Amon. For he says, I must honor my father, the ram god Zeus-Amon. Alexander is strange,
troubling. Once again, Darius raises a great army, and they would meet in battle at Abridis.
Once again, a glorious victory, and a cry. Babylon cheered Alexander the Conqueror. Alexander was
He was astonished by the high level of science, a culture going back thousands of years, a people he had thought primitive.
Nevertheless, he let himself go, indulging in the pleasures of the Orient.
And glory go to his head. He loses all sense of proportion.
Be ruled by your passions, Alexander. Dominate them.
Then he goes farther and farther into the unpredictable, fascinating Orient.
What are you doing now?
Looking for black gold. That's petroleum oil, you could say. You don't believe me? Take a look.
One day, it will bring my country the greatest wealth the world has known.
Caesar, one of the capital cities, is taken effortlessly.
And the faithful Parmenio will take the last enemy stronghold on the way to the fabulous Persepolis.
Had he really gone mad?
A violent father driven to excess, a mother caught up in myths claiming his father was a god.
Is it any wonder that Alexander was crazed? Unpredictable.
Went on, this is dead. Their victories are unchallenged, but the men are weary, and some of them protest.
Using all sense of reality, Alexander orders his friend, Philotas, to kill.
Then his faithful general, Parmenio.
And then came the turn of...
No, Alexander, you're not a god!
A god, Axolone, you succeeded through the courage and devotion of all your men.
Men like Philotas and Parmenio.
Many of these men had marched with Alexander for thousands of miles.
Together they had crossed deserts and high mountains,
Opening new routes by land and sea, many of the cities they founded are standing today, but weakened by malaria.
Perhaps victim of a criminal act, Alexander dies at the age of 33.
Yes, he was given to tragic excess, but thanks to him, Aristotle's philosophy found a place in Islamic doctrine.
And where he sowed Greek thought, a new civilization would take root and flourish: the Roman Empire.